we're gonna go back to the combine okay
long time ago okay you did no no you got
me on the 40 in I remember doing the
three cone drill and the 20 yard shuttle
here's the graphic there you go I got
more ups than you okay
this whiter man can jump higher than you
yes but damn for that last one
[Laughter]
somebody's a head coach and the other
ones working with you
that's Kliff Kingsbury with his last
year and here we are with a year under
his belt as head coach of the Arizona
Cardinals ease Kliff Kingsbury welcome
back coach great to see you
thanks for having me good to see y'all
it's lesson you've learned that you
didn't know when you were sitting here a
year ago that you know now that you wish
it may be known last year I think just
you know each game comes down to that
last possession so situational football
and then consistency in your approach
weekend we got mean you're gonna have
ups and downs over 16 weeks but you got
to be consistent and and those players
will follow even for you a guy who
played in close games and coach coach
like it is is it amazing how the NFL
literally I mean comes down to two or
three plays it really is in each week
you can point them out to your team and
they either wince your way or they
didn't right and that's gonna be a big
focuses all season the situational
football I mean you guys are in the
toughest division in football which is
the bad news the good news though Ka'ala
merged the real deal without question I
you know I was glad to see him win
Offensive Rookie of the Year so people
would give him the praise he deserves I
think it was he was overlooked because
other teams had better records but he
did special things did he exceed your
expectations for him coming in I knew
you know the skill set was was through
the roof and but I thought he really
developed as the season went on and some
some big areas you know leadership
qualities the approach to the game it's
just such a grind for those guys being
the face of the franchise at 22 but I
thought he handled it well matured and
we're hoping a year to we'll take one of
those big jumps like some of those guys
my Holmes and Jackson have done and
their young careers you always knew he
was a freak I mean I've heard your
comments whether you're at Texas Tech or
even before that anything about his game
that jumped out to you even more where
you were just like man he's better than
that than I thought I mean or were you
already like locked in on him yeah I
mean the skill set I always knew was
ridiculous I've never seen anybody move
on a field like that and the
throwing motion and accuracy things of
that name no I just can't get over the
power and accuracy consistency oh yeah I
can get it out but I think just his
approach to the game the way he sees the
game the information that he can bring
back to you after a series I was really
impressed by that yeah I was amazed by
the way the ball explodes out of his
hand and explodes into the hands of the
receiver he's got incredible zip and you
said something to cut my attention
because I've been saying the same thing
about calimary
we saw mahomes year two what he did
jackson year two what he did College got
more experience more accomplishment than
either of them had what are you doing to
prepare him for what could happen cuz it
could be he's the guy in 2020 that takes
the league by storm the way my Holmes
and Jackson did the two prior years as a
coach is exciting cuz I can point to
that and he sees it you know and he sees
it's attainable they did a great job but
those organizations building around
those two quarterbacks putting great
players around him and we're trying to
do the same but Tyler's expectation of a
self is so much higher than than any of
ours that that's what he expects and
then we just got to work hard this
offseason to try to get there all right
I mean air raid guns up doo-doo-doo like
okay like eighty four times in the damn
game and they beat us they went for it
on every fourth down so I got a great
experience of that damn offense okay but
tell us two things just about the
offense translating the NFL did you have
to tinker with it and then the
difference between NFL defenses and then
maybe what you saw in the big 12 on a
consistent basis are great questions
I think initially you know I tried to
kind of hold offense back and not run it
like we were going to in the preseason
and had that element surprise and I was
probably mistake because it was about
the first month there was a real feel
out process our personnel how we could
do it how we to be most effective and I
think after about the first month we got
a feel and we definitely teared some
things more tight in sets kind of play
to our personnel strength yes and then
you know defensively just a ton more man
coverage you know you played in the big
12 you know there are seams and zones
and and you know people running wide
open wide a little different right
different in this league and the the
defense coordinators are geniuses and
come up with great plans a week in and
week out so I think the approach to the
game weekend week out knowing you're
going to get a tough look is it's a
challenge
I almost fell off the chair I want to
say week - when Kyler Murray went under
the Center in Baltimore were you like
okay I can't believe it's not we
executed the exchange yeah yeah and
taking a lot under spinner at this point
but we're working towards that it's an
element of the game we want to get
better at and I think it'll expand this
season yeah today in the NFL at the
quarterback position I think it's a 365
day a year job even in the offseason
you're working you're training you're
thinking you're studying how do you
react when you hear Kyler Murray from
time to time use about playing baseball
while he's playing football yeah he's
not playing baseball
[Laughter]
no but he's such a competitor I think he
just wants people to know hey don't
forget that I was a top 10 pick in
baseball as well and could do it if if
it was actually possible okay
when did you feel comfortable like when
were you like okay this NFL thing you
know coaching the sidelines yelling at
refs when did it finally see I'm still
working through that I'm definitely much
more settled I think as a staff we feel
much more settled going into year two
but it's it's so much to take on there's
so many different levels to it but I'm
enjoying the process yeah do you have
any officials that you've gotten used to
seeing for some of your games that you
like to yell at more than others I try
to keep it pretty low-key I don't think
it helps too much but those guys they'll
come back at you on this league like
they won't just take it so it makes it
kind of fun and your division like
that's the other thing like holy cow can
I NFC East for crying out loud
where we used to be it's it's weekend
week at them you got some offensive
geniuses and you got Pete who's one of
the best coaches of all time college or
NFL but you got to bring it they've all
had their run and we're hoping to kind
of build this thing and catch up to some
of those guys okay
after the Chiefs win the Super Bowl you
reach out to Patrick I did I did
actually saw him this weekend just fired
up for him he's such a I mean y'all got
to know him a little bit but such a good
person as phenomenas is on the field
he's even better off you see me in Vegas
for the fight I did I did I didn't get
as good of seats as him but I got to see
him before it and he's just he's doing
great
he's got a lot on his plate but handling
it so well what do you hear what what
goes through your brain when you hear
expanded playoffs and one extra game how
do you feel about that yeah I'm excited
about I mean you're playing for
pre-season anyways so you can knock one
of those off and then get an extra game
and then the playoffs to be able to tell
your team hey we're still in it and as
long as possible I think you're positive
for everybody yeah I hear that
what's your objective for this year
especially in light of the divisionary
cuz every I would want to make the place
on the Super Bowl you got the 49ers -
Seahawks and the Rams like what's a
successful season for you
year to the show you know improvement
really I felt we implemented everything
now we got to improve those processes
and and just show improvement in all
three phases and if we do that you know
we'll be in the mix at Dan one player
just give me one all right your first
year you know in the NFL you just went
like holy cow I can't get over how good
that players how big he is or I would
say fits I mean just when you watch that
guy each and every day Fitzgerald it's
it's insane the way he still practices
the last week you know we're playing the
Rams we're out of it they're out of it
it's Friday it's raining outside he's
diving for passes at the Friday present
he's just an absolute machine and can
still really get done okay that was an
easy one now give me one on another team
somebody like I don't want to see that
guy I mean I know you played Russell
Wilson I was free we played Lamar you
know Lamar Lamar you play the zone read
and you're waiting on him and he still
pulls it and runs fast you mean he's
that freaky talent-wise his
explosiveness and right and he throws it
better than I anticipate him he really
had a hell of a year yeah all right well
cliff you had a hell of a year with the
Arizona Cardinals we wish you all the
best for 2020 congratulations on the
success
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports